hello everyone in many areas of science
engineering and certainly mathematics we
have to make surface plots now it is
quite common to find demonstrations of
surface plots over rectangular domains
but it is not that common over
non-rectangular domains uh
so I thought that will be useful if I
can demonstrate to you live how we can
draw such a surface plot over a
non-rectangular domain so as you can see
on the screen we have such an example uh
this is the surface sine X Plus cos y
and the domain of Interest here
is this
circular domain please note that this is
not directly the projection I have
actually just drawn the domain here
okay so over this domain we are going to
have our surface plot denoted by this Z
variable or the Z function so how can
you do it so let me demonstrate this to
you using python uh
so I'll
use symbolic python to Define my
function
so I'm starting from absolute scratch
I'll Define the
the symbolic variables
X and Y first
and then
I'll Define this
function
Z so this is sine X Plus cos y so far so
good
now this is just a symbolic function we
want to be able to uh plot this thing
numerically
so what I mean by that is we actually
have to input numerical values within
this X and Y we also have to understand
that our domain of interest is a certain
circular annulus so
let's say our
domain is a circular annulus so I'm just
using markdown to use this to write this
out
oh
so
let's say
we have this as our domain x square plus
y Square lying between a square and B
Square
all right
but first of all let's see how we can do
this over the rectangular domain that is
not our solution but let's just see how
we can do it so uh of course for actual
plotting I cannot proceed with this
symbolic thing I have to uh
use numerical values for A and B I also
have to convert this Z surface a defined
symbolically into something which into
which I can put numerical values for
that I'll use uh
lambdification the Lambda function
facility within python so let me Define
this the Z Lambda
all right
and I'm going to use this Z Lambda later
on to do the actual plotting uh
now I also will import this numpy
huh
I'll set the value as 2 and B as 5 these
are just example values you can choose
anything as long as a is less than b
and I will set my domain first of all as
a rectangular domain bounded by this
founded from minus B to B
so for the X data
I'll set
this from minus B minus 1 to B plus 1.
I similarly I I just copy paste from the
previous line
so now I have my rectangular domain
I'll also set up this X and Y uh
using this mesh grid operator
okay now I'm set
uh so I'll let's try to plot this thing
in the rectangular domain itself so I'll
import
uh let me first set this as
this is what I want I'll import matte
plot live
dot Pi plot as PLT the idiomatic vein
which is done and I'll set up my figure
uh
very basic thing here
foreign
I have to specify this in order to make
it understand that I am interested in
creating 3D plots okay so now let me use
the plot surface facility Within
matplotlib to
actually plot this thing so remember
that I had defined this Z Lambda surface
I'm going to use that and input
the values X and Y which I had created
earlier using numpy so let's see what it
gives us
so you see this thing that we have
obtained here is the plot for Z is equal
to sine X Plus cos y
but if I just rotate it you can clearly
see that this is over a rectangular
domain going from minus B so our B was 5
you see it goes from -6 to plus six
that's how I had defined it this is very
it's very nice so
nice domain of Interest so how can we
actually limit our surface plot in our
domain of Interest which is actually
this one this uh this circular annulus
so what I'm going to use now is uh
referred to as masking so basically I
don't so just think of it like this that
I have the surface plot within the
rectangular domain but I just want to
switch off those areas of this
rectangular domain which are outside the
circular annulus so anything which is
lying outside the circular annulus will
be masked off
so
up it's
quite interesting how we can do it so
first of all we will Define our mask
using this r i mean you can use any
variable here I am just using R for the
mask masking so x square plus y Square
now remember that we want to mask those
regions which are outside the circular
annulus so x square plus y Square less
than a square that's
one region and that has to be
uh
Union okay with the other region which
is lying outside the circular annulars
so basically this region
so this is our mask but we have to
utilize this mask to create our masked
variable
so
the way we go about doing it is
to this little magic command must where
please note that this is very much
within the numpy uh so this np.ma.master
this is very much within the numpy
facilities
so first of all the mask and then
the Z Lambda so basically the second
argument is uh
giving us the entire thing over which uh
we have to apply the mask
and now I have to plot not the Z Lambda
rather the Z masked so let's see if this
thing works
so you see I have this thing if I can
just rotate this a little bit you'll see
uh I have this thing okay so
I hope
this is clear enough
uh
we can of course make a little bit fancy
ah it's not absolutely necessary but uh
you can set it up like this
just a better visualization uh
okay so all the access are dimensioned
properly
so that's it uh so now we have actually
a
our surface plot over the
non-rectangular domain
okay and please note that because I had
started from the symbolic python it
actually helps me think in terms of
variables which I would actually think
if I were to do this I mean or if I had
to do this thing mathematically on a
piece of paper so I hope this you find
this useful thank you very much